les de bois d'olives de la fondation
père favron héberge 90 personnes âgées
dépendantes dont beaucoup présentent des
troubles psychiatriques
chaque mardi les résidents sont invités
à participer à un atelier pas comme les
autres place à l'expression l'atelier
d'art-thérapie commence en douceur
il faut que les gens se sentent bien oui
alors on arrive en moi un petit café on
prend le temps de s'installer
on prend le temps de ressentir des
choses n'a créé cet espace avec beaucoup
de couleurs
je tiens à mettre une nappe en tissu
qu'on est
voilà des choses à voir des choses à
sentir à ressentir dans cette salle est
effectivement quelque chose qui soit et
stimulant mais voilà une façon agréable
l'art thérapie est une méthode visant à
utiliser le potentiel d'expression
artistique et la créativité d'une
personne à des fins psychothérapeutique
ou pour le développement personnel
isabelle ravel l'art thérapeute de
l'établissement fait partie de l'équipe
paramédicale
elle accompagne depuis quatre ans les
résidents passent vraiment on est dans
un processus de créativité notre notre
esprit notre corps est canalisée par une
activité
ça libère des émotions en avant tout on
utilise des couleurs des matières ça
stimule la sensorialité comme salah pèse
donc il ya déjà une partie à
thérapeutique
on va dire de base l'art-thérapie
s'adapte ici aux problématiques des
résidents de l'établissement qui sont
concernés par des troubles
psychiatriques ronis
l'art thérapie permet de développer ce
qu'on peut appeler des capacités
compensatoires on utilise ce qui est
encore possible
chez certaines personnes on réveille ses
capacités là et on se rend compte qu
avec le temps si les séances elles sont
bien ritualisé si les coupures sont pas
trop longue
sur un temps donné d'une année deux
années moins que ça ces capacités là
peuvent évoluer se développer est ce que
tu te souviens comment on fait des
héron tu sais faire faut arrêter le
geste rappelle à utiliser des couleurs
on remet le corps en mouvement ont remis
l'esprit en mouvement en stimule des
parties positif de choix
aujourd'hui nous nous trouvons donc sur
les pâtes de bois d'olives qui accueille
donc des personnes âgées souffrant de
handicap psychique souvent cronie 6 et
c'est pour cette raison que nous avons
souhaité développer avec le médecin
coordonnateur de l'établissement tout
une prise en charge avec des activités à
visée thérapeutique est également des
activités de type occupationnel donc
quand on parle d'activité à visée
thérapeutique il s'agit essentiellement
d'intervention de paramédicaux et
notamment de l'art thérapeute ça c'est
l'image de soi pour un des patients une
partie tourmenté d idée qui trotte dans
la tête et on essaye de les exprimer de
les faire redescendre dans le corps et
ses décisions sont eux qui décident
ensemble et aussi communiquer sur la
partie ambivalente de la personnalité
avec une partie de tout à fait heureuse
et détendue et une partie beaucoup de
torture et des idées agressive la
tiennent leur thérapie révèle des
fragments de vie madame leveneur
souhaite revoir son tableau un grand
format un souvenir une expérience
émotionnelle qui est extérioriser est
désormais qui a sa propre existence au
travers de leurs qu'elle compose et si
je suis une femme
enfin n va mal ça qui atteint bébé qui
est pas made in est d'accord et pourquoi
vous avez dessiné cette femme si
j'écrivais
et là me suis mis tous rêvé de ça oui
et si ils rendent chez v d'accord et ça
c'est des lampes à trèbes les grands
cheveux ou ici d'amour est d'accord et
vous vous aviez des grands cheveux quoi
moi à moi j'avais bien joué mais je
rappelle que le téléphone et vous même
vous avez eu des enfants comment il n'y
a rien
et ben oui mais pas eu d'enfant donc non
moins venti admis un outil dit la mairie
les objectifs en art-thérapie selon les
personnes ou sont très différents il ya
des personnes qui ont vraiment le besoin
d'eux on va dire de mieux comprendre
leur vie de résoudre des partis trop
douloureuse de les soigner de les
réparer pour mieux vivre leur leur
voyage voilà sa démarche d'ouverture de
réparation de bien-être n'est possible
qu'avec le consentement de la personne
et un total respect de sa dignité
cette participation des résidents fait
partie du projet d'établissement n'est
pas réservée exclusivement ce public
psychiatrique un d'accord ou
psychotiques
on peut également le mettre en
application pour par exemple des
personnes qui souffrent de démence ou de
pathologies de type e alzheimer par
exemple comme nous avons sur les deux
autres établissements
donc c'est également ça donne également
d'excellents résultats il s'appelle
rappelle annie de ces ateliers sur trois
est pas un accompagnement qui rappelle
qu'il n'y a pas d'âge pour continuer
d'explorer les couleurs